ahora mismo nos encontramos en Osmani en
este edificio cree en los servicios de
rescate que hay personas por varios
motivos porque hace algo más de una hora
que estaban los militares turcos y han
decretado con sus sensores de calor que
aquí dentro hay probablemente fuentes de
calor y por lo tanto están ahora mismo
acelerando las tareas de rescate incluso
cuentan los vecinos que ayer por la
noche uno de los antiguos habitantes de
este antiguo edificio de ocho plantas
mandó un mensaje de SMS a sus familiares
pidiendo ayuda desde el interior de
estas mismas runas que están aquí detrás
en este sitio como muchos lugares hay
también bomberos y equipos de rescate
internacionales aquí hay franceses pero
por toda la región hay desplegados a
equipos de rescato tanto a franceses
como españoles húngaros europeos rusos
incluso y está llegando ayuda y
armamento y ayuda y Transportes
Internacionales para hacer hospitales de
campaña no solo en esta ciudad de
osmaníes sino en toda la región afectada
son 10 provincias turcas afectadas que
ahora mismo están viviendo una
catástrofe sin precedentes en los
últimos años en Turquía